tv romances are a cherished part of pop
culture
uncle phil and aunt viv jim and pam
corey and topanga
we love them all but some tv couples are
downright unhealthy
these are the most rotten romances in
television history
buffy the vampire slayer spike and buffy
epitomize toxicity
long before they hook up spike develops
a creepy infatuation with buffy after
his longtime girlfriend and fellow
vampire drusilla dumps him
when buffy brutally rejects him he gets
warren evil nerd extraordinaire to
create a creepy robot in her likeness
making a sex bot of someone definitely
isn't a healthy way to deal with your
feelings spike
following her death and subsequent
resurrection she feels lost and hooks up
with spike
a lot to escape her hollowness but ends
up hating herself even more
sure spike cares for her in his own
twisted way
but when she finally comes to her senses
and breaks things off with him
he tries to assault her in an attempt to
earn her love and respect
the vamp goes through hell to get a soul
while their time together during his
soulless days is toxic
and horrible he eventually becomes the
man that puffy deserves
miss piggy and kermit's 2015 breakup was
a long time coming
when they first graced the screen as a
couple in the 70s on the muppet show
their toxic back and forth was played
for laughs but boy does it get brutal
miss piggy continuously punches her bow
who's also her boss
talk about an uncomfortable workplace
dynamic
when abc revived the series in 2015
domestic abuse
didn't play so funny anymore in what was
both a brilliant marketing campaign
and the right plot choice the duo aired
their messy split as part of the new
series
and who better to provide what was
essentially couples counseling
and jimmy kimmel although their romance
remains dead
miss piggy and kermit have worked
together professionally since their
split
on projects like the muppets and 2020s
muppets now
demon ruby shows up on supernatural in
season 3
quickly convincing sam that she's on
their side while dean remains skeptical
with ruby's original meat suit rotting
somewhere sam makes her possess the
comatose body of a woman who just died
from there they develop romantic
feelings partaking in typical
couple stuff like hooking up and
telekinetically exercising demons
when your girlfriend is force-feeding
you demon blood to supercharge said
telekinesis
that should probably raise some red
flags yet sam refuses to see what's
right in front of him
till the demon successfully coerces him
into releasing lucifer from hell
ruby's response to manipulating her
boyfriend for over a year
i'm awesome however it isn't all bad
actress genevieve cortez and jared
padalecki fell in love during the steamy
throws of on-screen demon passion
and have since married and had multiple
children
it's not surprising that a show filmed
in the 50s would have a romanticized
toxic marriage as the centerpiece
at first glance it seems like ricky and
lucy from i love lucy have the perfect
marriage
but you're quickly confronted with the
toxic roles women and men were expected
to play in the 50s
ricky often scolds lucy for wanting to
spend time with him
and at one point she thinks he's trying
to kill her his response is to give her
a mickey
imagine how messed up a relationship has
to be for you to think your spouse is
trying to kill you
imagine how much worse it is when his
response to your suspicions is to drug
you
small scenes like this add up throughout
the show's run creating a much different
picture of the supposedly happy couple
from modern viewers to cringe at
while gilmore girls dean forrester
starts out as the super sweet boy next
door
things quickly take a turn after he and
rory begin dating
everything dean starts out loving about
rory turns into an issue
including her academic studies her
relationship with her mom
and her compassion plus any time rory
dares to interact with another guy
even in an educational setting dean
flies into a possessive rage
dean tries to control every facet of
rory's life and blows up at her when she
doesn't return his i love you during
their three-month anniversary
i love you rory
yeah did you hear me
still despite him dumping her on the
spot rory still pines for him
to make things more uncomfortable dean
mutters rory's name the night before his
rushed wedding to another woman
even worse rory and dean hook up during
the marriage which ends with his
belongings scattered on the lawn
the divorce leads to one last attempt to
rekindle their toxic relationship
which to be fair should have been over
years earlier
most toxic relationships don't end with
the death of someone's entire family
but then most people aren't teen wolf's
derrick hale his worst girlfriend
kate argent enters the picture after
derek's first love
paige dies from the werewolf by he
orchestrated
derek is riddled with guilt which makes
seducing him all too easy for kate
the 20-something werewolf hunter inserts
herself into teenage derek's life
convincing him she loves him why
so she can burn his entire family alive
obviously
when derek is magically turned back into
his 15 year old self
kate ditches her murder plans and
decides to use him to gain access to his
family's vault instead
kate and derek certainly weren't
destined for wedding bells and hopefully
the former hunter is bringing hell's
bell somewhere fiery in the afterlife
harley quinn needs to stop calling the
joker puddin and throw a pudding pie in
his face instead
in her very first appearance in batman
the animated series
mr j roughly shoves harley to the other
side of his desk without a second
thought
and his abuse towards her only gets
worse from there the joker moves from
shoving her onto his desk to throwing
her out the window
and he continually chips away at her
confidence
it's baffling that people still call the
couple relationship goals
because they're anything but luckily
there's always birds of prey
which follows a version of harley who's
finally cut the joker out of her life
and the harley quinn series which sees
her enter into a far more healthy
relationship with poison ivy
how do you doom a marriage before it
even begins say your ex's name during
the wedding ceremony
it works out great for ross on friends i
ross take the emily take thee rachel
though they're often considered the tv
darlings of the 90s
ross and rachel bring out the nastiest
sides of each other in their decade of
will they or won't they drama
ross's longtime obsession with rachel
leads to his insecurity in their
relationship
causing him to question almost
everything rachel does when they're
dating
or even broken up since he doesn't deem
himself worthy of her
he begins to act unworthy of her funny
how that works
rachel isn't without blame either their
couple is fraught with jealousy
and manipulation on both ends and to
ross's dismay
being on a break does not warrant
hooking up with someone just hours after
pausing the relationship with your
so-called dream girl
ross and rachel are one of the most
unsatisfying end game pairs
on tv what happens when you take a
wannabe playboy and pair him with a
clingy romantic
on and off for seven years nothing good
whereas most toxic tv relationships have
at least some redeeming
aspects the offices ryan and kelly are a
hot mess from the jump
ryan only wants kelly when she starts
dating someone else
yet he completely disregards the fact
that kelly wants a real
romantic relationship that ends in
wedding bells meanwhile
kelly uses unknowing men to make ryan
jealous
a vicious cycle ensues in which ryan
sabotages those relationships
only to bail on her right after they
hook up
they're both also incredibly
manipulative whether we're talking about
kelly faking a pregnancy
or ryan proposing to her when she
finally moves on
fully admitting he'll probably change
his mind later
finally we see some character
development when kelly turns down ryan's
proposal
she gets happily married to a sweet and
loving doctor and
leaves scranton to start her life with
him but because kelly and ryan can't
seem to live apart
ryan ditches his infant son and runs
away with kelly in the series finale
goodbye character development hello life
of misery
gossip girls chuck and blair take the
cake for torment and betrayal
the couple just can't quit each other or
their vicious games
to chuck in blair's credit though at
least they acknowledge that they're
toxic together
they just don't care enough to throw in
the towel their pattern of dangerous
mind games persists right to the very
end of the show
when they have a quickie wedding so
blair doesn't have to testify against
chuck
there's nothing more romantic than a
rushed wedding ceremony with sirens
blaring in the background
shortly after killing your own father
manhattan's elite needs a lot of therapy
all the best romances begin with someone
turning their ex
into the cops right orange is the new
blacks alex and piper
are so afraid of being without each
other that they throw each other into
incarceration
just so they don't have to be alone
underneath the possessive behavior
jealousy and frequent cheating the
couple does love each other
but boy do they make each other prove it
so how can a relationship survive after
both partners have knarked on each other
repeatedly
by being physically intimate obviously
when piper is released from prison and
alex is still inside
alex tries to set piper free when she's
transferred to a prison further away
but apparently this doesn't take the
series final moments see piper visiting
alex in her new digs
determined to make their prison marriage
work however the ending would be a lot
more satisfactory if fans hadn't spent
seven years
watching the couple make each other
absolutely miserable in prison
at first it's easy to sympathize with
lex luthor's bad luck in the love
department on smallville
his first wife uses him for his riches
after all but nothing excuses what he
does to lana lang
lex's laundry list of shady activity
includes putting cameras in lana's
bedroom when she moves into the luther
mansion
cutting her off from friends and family
and making sure she doesn't find out
that clark still loves her
if that weren't bad enough lex drugs her
into thinking she's pregnant
given that he becomes a mad scientist
it's not a complete stretch that he
would pull something like this
after playing doctor with her hormone
levels lex tricks lana into marrying him
using the fake pregnancy to squash her
hesitation
as his first wife tricked lex into
marriage with pheromones
you'd think lex would be a little less
gung-ho about doing the same thing to
someone he supposedly cares about
apparently not it's hard to watch lex go
from the caring
empathetic guy we see in season 1 to
this monster
really lex should probably just stop
dating they say you should marry your
best friend
but no one says you should marry your
friend of me yet al and peg bundy
act like they hate each other in almost
every married with children episode
their toxic dynamic is play for laughs
that probably seemed funnier in the 80s
than they do now
between pegs savage barbs about al's
hygiene and al's continued mockery of
peg's unemployment
one wonders do they even like each other
sure
they're possessive of each other but
that comes across more like ownership
than love
when pegg suspects al of cheating on her
she disguises herself as an exotic
dancer at the club he frequents
making him fall in love with her in that
disguise the guy can't even recognize
his own wife at a dance club
but even worse than that he's cheating
on his wife
with his wife this marriage is a mess
and a half
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one